all right what's going on guys this is
rob and we are back with kingdom come
part two yes we are part dos now here's
the thing superman and the justice
league as we know them have effectively
returned right superman wonder woman
hawkman all these different characters
they've all basically returned back to
the landscape so what we're looking at
now is a scenario where the superheroes
of old have returned to face the
superheroes of new now this is where
things get really really interesting
because on the surface we would look at
that and we would say okay so like the
day saved and everything is going to be
sorted out we're pretty far from that
actually and things are going to get a
lot worse before they get better so what
this does is it initially picks up at
the statue of liberty and you've
basically got this crazy guy right like
the american commando and his minutemen
is what he calls him now the thing about
this here is he just kind of goes on
this just ultra i wouldn't even call it
patriotic so much just ultra insane rant
where he says like this is my country
right for years the american mando and
the minutemen have protected the us from
foreign threats only to have overlooked
the most insidious menace of all the
poor tired huddled masses camping on our
shores begging for citizenship you
immigrants dare expect sanctuary
america's not as big as it used to be
for god's sakes kansas is gone we can't
house you now we can't even feed you now
but still you force yourselves on us
well no more today the america mando
declares war on the wretched refuse and
at that point you basically have all
these guys who start attacking these
people who were looking to make their
way into the united states now while all
that goes on what you have is another of
these really just anti-hero groups out
there that just attacked the amir
commandos and again as we talked about
before what you have here in this
instance are basically feral superheroes
it's the best way to look at it that
traditionally in dc comics the emergence
of superman while he didn't really
present himself as the de facto leader
in the standard by which all superheroes
should follow it just kind of ended up
that way the superman's morale was
almost unquestionable and incorruptible
what you have here are basically people
with powers and no leadership whatsoever
right it's an answer to the question
what will people do in a circumstance
when there is no one to lead them
they'll do whatever it is they want to
do and the the rules or any collateral
damage won't really make any difference
it's a really really interesting
critique on people who are like we
should not have an ordered government
okay well if you look at the nature of
humanity what is the average person
without someone telling them what to do
or where to go they're people who just
do things arbitrarily and never take
into account the wants or desires or the
consequences of their actions on other
people it just becomes lawlessness and
it'll only lead to chaos and destruction
and so it's really really interesting
how this is critiqued how that concept
is looked at and put through the lens of
these superheroes because what you get
is in the middle of all this you have
the justice league that arrives here now
contrary to to what you might think in
the sense of superman and then just show
up and start pummeling everybody while
they do bring an end to this fight what
superman does is he basically presents
himself and the justice league to these
people and basically gives them an
option right you can join us or you can
be dealt with now there is a way in
which they're dealt with and that way
doesn't necessarily come until well
really towards you know in this story
but it's one of those things where
superman's hand is kind of forced
instead what he does is he kind of
repairs the statue of liberty as best he
can kind of presenting himself as a
beacon of hope and then in turn
basically uses the numbers of all these
vigilantes and brings them to his side
now that's an important distinction that
i want to make here when it comes to
these different heroes out here again
they're not really villains they're more
just feral like they've never really had
any direction they've never been taught
any better one of the things to know and
what's kind of interesting is this book
in a lot of ways throws into sharp
relief the idea of like social
constructs different things like that
like if you scale out right if you look
at like how people function on a
day-to-day life or look at your life and
then you scale out and look at it at a
macro scale we as human beings largely
just do things because that's just what
you're supposed to do we don't question
it we don't really ask why we just do it
because everybody else does that social
norms and social constructs are largely
just created in order to provide a sense
of comfort and that anybody who deviates
outside of these unspoken social norms
has to be quote unquote corrected and
brought back in again even if what we're
doing is entirely stupid and ridiculous
and doesn't really make any sense a
really good example of this is the mitch
hedberg joke right that like escalators
that are broken are basically just
stairs so why would you be an idiot and
take stairs instead of taking the
escalator right but we don't think about
that we're just like oh the escalator's
not working i'll take the stairs instead
even though that's basically stairs
and we all do that and so that's why
it's kind of interesting when somebody
just sort of looks up and says why am i
doing this right because the response of
everybody around them is shut up stop
asking questions get your head back down
and then they just continue on just like
they did before right so you know
violating social norms is kind of looked
down upon which really kind of makes you
beg the question who's the one that
really is screwed up here is it the one
who's asking the question why am i
following these social norms or is it
the one who's telling that person to
stop asking questions and to follow
those social norms but the thing about
this is that these heroes don't have a
leader there's no one out there for you
know to really tell them here is how
heroes are supposed to act they're feral
and so superman presenting himself in
this way is quite literally giving these
people the kind of you know person to
follow the kind of ideology to a degree
now you're gonna find over the course of
this that there is a lot of hypocrisy
that goes on there and a lot of things
that don't necessarily seem to make
sense but following all of that superman
and his guys you know the justice league
appear basically before the united
nations at a kind of press conference
and they say look like we've been gone
for a really long time right a lot of
you or at least some of you all may
remember who we are some of you may not
but the fact that we've been gone that's
our mistake and he says in our absence a
new breed of metahumans has arisen a
vast phalanx of self-styled heroes
unwilling to preserve life or defend the
defenseless a legion of vigilantes who
have perverted their great powers who
have forsworn the responsibilities due
to them we have returned to teach them
the meaning of truth and justice
together we will guide this new breed
with wisdom and if necessary with force
above all we will restore order we will
make things right again now there is an
attempt by various members of the press
to ask some questions but for the most
part they're not necessarily answered
there is a point where superman is asked
well what if this leads to you having to
face magog to which superman just kind
of looks away and seems to avoid the
question and then basically just ends up
taking off now one of the things that we
are kind of given here and at least you
know we're given this kind of moment
where superman transitions to wayne
manor of course we knew it was only
going to be a matter of time before he
would confront bruce wayne and this
interaction between the two is really
really cool because when superman gets
there wayne manor's trashed i mean this
place is just torn up i mean obviously
it's just experienced some pretty rough
times and superman finds batman down in
the cave but one of the things to notice
here is that there is no happiness from
batman to see superman and in fact this
exchange is phenomenal because what you
have here is superman who says uh batman
i know you're here right like you cannot
hide from me and the response of batman
is i bow to your superior wisdom after
all you know all about hiding don't you
clark and it's one of those things where
batman holds a lot of animosity towards
superman now what's interesting here is
that the debate between the two is that
superman has always believed that
mankind should be led to a better future
right if the world becomes a better
place it's because superman and the
actions of the superheroes show humanity
that they can become better but you
could argue that's a very naive
perspective right that superman is john
tuturo from miller's crossing right when
you have gabriel byrne with a gun
pointed at his head and superman says
look into your heart right that's what
he is whereas batman is the realist
right batman looks at humanity and says
no if given the opportunity humanity
will just do crazy and violent things i
mean look at these vigilantes that exist
out there they're an answer to your
question superman what is humanity at
its core what will humanity become when
you take away consequences it's the
grocery carts litmus test those you guys
who are unfamiliar with that the grocery
cart litmus test is this really really
fascinating ideology what it says is
that when you go to the grocery store
and you buy your groceries and you put
them in the cart and then you put them
in the car and so on and so forth and
then you're done the grocery cart is
sitting right there and that's when the
test comes into play right there's no
reward for putting the grocery cart back
inside the cart corral that's what it's
called i don't know what it's actually
called but there's a there's no reward
for doing that but it is the right thing
to do however if you don't do that and
you just leave the grocery cart out
there in the middle of the parking lot
there's no punishment for that so what
will a person do when there's no reward
for doing the right thing but no
punishment for doing the wrong thing
what will they end up doing here and the
argument that batman's making here
albeit absent the grocery cart litmus
test although i would love to have seen
that in the comic
as he says the world in which you see
clark is the answer to that question the
world that you see out there that's what
it looks like when you have metahumans
where there's no consequences for doing
the wrong thing but no benefit for doing
the right thing outside of a you know
moral pat on the back they'll do
whatever they want to do and that right
and wrong won't matter anymore right and
wrong or completely and totally
irrelevant there's just simply what a
man can do and what a man can't do and
that's it those are the only rules that
apply here so you championing how great
humanity can become the evidence runs
contrary to everything that you believe
and that's why batman had basically
turned gotham city into what's
essentially a dictatorship where he
rules it with an iron fist now there's a
few different reasons why this had
happened the first one is because once
batman's identity became publicly known
bane and two-face showed up and just
wrecked wayne manor now of course they
weren't able to access the bat cave
hence the reason why all this stuff is
still intact the other reason why is
because there came a point uh where
essentially arkham asylum was just
annihilated and basically all the
villains that were in it were basically
killed so there's very few of any of
batman's traditional villains left if
any at all instead now it's all just
sort of meta humans that are there the
meta humans those ones that just kind of
do whatever it is that they want
presumably dealt with batman's villains
but the reality is that in the absence
of all that the gotham city in the eyes
of bruce wayne is a utopia there is no
crime none of that stuff now people
don't necessarily have the same free
will that they had before but as we've
seen so far with regards to all these
meta-humans what will people do with
complete and total freedom they'll go
crazy right they'll basically destroy
things that that right and wrong simply
won't matter it's just it's a really
really interesting idea here and i love
the way this is put together and so
that's where you have just kind of a
splitting of ideologies here that at the
end of the day there is no real way to
find any measure of unification and in
fact batman even goes as far to tell
superman you are just as naive as you
ever were like you really believe that
humanity is this great thing but rest
assured right like there's myself and
the people i work with whose names you
will never know we see humanity for what
it really is and what you see here in
gotham city we will try to extend this
to the rest of the world because
humanity by its very nature needs to be
controlled if there's no one telling
people where to go or what to do then
people will be lost they'll be just
chaotic and nonsensical right they'll do
things that are quite literally worse
for society because whether or not
something's better for society won't
matter to them they'll operate on their
own selfish instincts the world has
shown us that humanity has shown us that
so we have to control them because they
they cannot control themselves now
initially superman ends up leaving
instead of just creating a confrontation
with batman he basically walks away and
you end up finding out that the various
people that bruce wayne has on his side
include people like ted cord and dinah
lance and oliver queen that these are
some pretty intelligent and capable
forces that are out there more so than
that what batman also says is with the
justice league returned and the justice
league reforming what superman's going
to do is all those different meta humans
out there who were just rogue and doing
their own thing it's only going to be a
matter of time before they basically
join his ranks which means the the ranks
of the justice league are going to
bolster which means we have to find our
own team we have to build our own team
up this includes people like like black
adam it includes people like dr fate and
so on and so forth we've got to build
our own team and so what you end up
getting is this moment where as time
goes on you have superman who is meeting
with different groups out there right
these these meta humans and whatnot who
are just rampaging and causing all kinds
of problems and whatnot and basically
teaching them direction now not all of
them join the side of superman and we're
not really given an immediate answer as
to what it is that happens to them
instead for the most part the ones who
do agree with superman basically join
his side but what we end up doing is
transitioning to another group out there
which is basically called the mankind
liberation front and what this is is a
coming together of humans across the
world now one of the funny things here
is despite its name not all of them are
directly tied to humanity i mean they
are but they also kind of have they have
powers essentially so you could argue
meta humans and the reason why i say
this is because one of the first people
that we're met with is vandal savage now
depending on how you want to look at
dc's history you could take that
traditional history of vandal savage as
it exists regarding dionysium and the
substance he consumed that basically
made him immortal you can apply that to
kingdom come if you want to and say in
this alternate reality that's basically
how he came to be of course that whole
dionysium thing was established in the
new 52 batman run by scott snyder uh
vandal savage is not just a guy who's
going to live for like probably 85 to 90
years and then die of age he's immortal
but regardless this this mankind
liberation front is headed up by lex
luthor and you have a few different
people here one of whom is al zoufash
who's basically the successor to rajal
ghul then you also have of course lord
naga you've got selena kyle you've got
the riddler edward nigma and the cool
thing is that what you find is that
behind the scenes with a lot of things
that's going on the mankind liberation
front is actually working to make life
more difficult for humanity and i know
it seems counterintuitive that they're
doing things like impeding rescue
efforts right or they're getting the
getting in the way of uh food and
resources that are being brought to the
united states from different places and
so on and so when the question is being
asked how is any of this helping
humanity which is the charter under
which you operate the response of lex
luthor is simply no pain no gain he says
our objective is to heighten the tension
between humans and metahumans to bring
it to a head so that humans have no
choice but to reclaim the being of world
power regardless of the cost there will
be war bloodshed but in the end mankind
will once again rule the earth now the
reason why he says that of course
obviously he wants to be him and this
council that rules everything but the
reason why he makes this argument is
because for years what has happened is
humanity has handed the reigns over to
superheroes to keep them protected
that's the way it was when you initially
had the justice league it's the way it
was when the justice league disbanded
and we got this new generation of heroes
humanity ultimately bit off more than
they could chew they regretted the
decision they made but there was no one
willing to step up and save humanity
from itself now that the justice league
has returned humanity hasn't changed
it's not doing anything different than
it was before it's not like the
reformation of the of the justice league
led to humanity saying oh my god i see
the light we clearly made a mistake by
looking at superheroes and asking them
to save us no it was humanity looking at
the justice league and saying man the
world's such a terrible place save us
justice league show us a better way and
then when humanity made the decision
that it made which is what we'll talk
about later on in the story the justice
league disbanded and the anti-heroes
that rose up humanity was like yes
you're the ones we want and then when
the anti-heroes did exactly what they
would do which was showing really in a
lot of ways becoming a mirror for
humanity itself that humans were just
like no we don't want this this is not
what we wanted we want we want the
justice league back so the justice
league came back and they're like
justice league these meta humans are
going crazy you have to save us so it's
one of those things where humanity never
quite takes responsibility for itself it
never looks around at any point and says
maybe i'm the one responsible for all of
this instead it just blames everything
else on everybody else and so the idea
of the mankind liberation front is to
force the hand of humanity to make
things so dire that what the majority of
the human race does right what people in
general do is they look at metahumans
and say metahumans in their entirety are
the problem many humans are the reason
why all of this is the way it is we have
to get meta humans we have to get rid of
them completely and then once that's
done that will lead to humanity
re-inheriting the earth quote-unquote as
lex luthor puts it now the other part of
this is that lex does have an ace up a
sleeve it's one thing to interrupt trade
routes and to make resources more scarce
it's another to actually be able to
stand against superman and the justice
league what we end up finding out here
is the ace in the hole that lex luthor
has is actually shazam but before we
figure that out
before we find out about that what we
end up doing here is basically picking
up with a with a point where superman
and wonder woman go to visit aquaman now
initially they asked aquaman for aid but
the reality here is aquaman's like no
like i'm not i'm not helping you guys at
all one i never really wanted to be
aquaman i never wanted to be your
aquaman i was there more or less because
i wanted to ensure atlantis was
protected and because i didn't even
really initially know what you guys were
about right so in a lot of ways for
those of you guys coming from marvel it
was when black panther initially joined
the avengers he joined them to keep an
eye on him not because he actually
wanted to be a part of the team and
because he believed in their cause as
time went on aquaman did to a degree but
the reality here is that when the time
came when it was obvious the justice
league wasn't going to reform superman
was done he had walked away and there
would be no one there to look out for
atlantis that aquaman's response was i'm
going to look after my kingdom myself
whatever happens in the service world i
don't care so long as it doesn't impede
here now this is in reality and it's one
of the things that wonder woman points
out it really is aquaman sticking his
head in the sand and just waiting for
the danger to pass or hoping the danger
passes the question she has is how long
do you think this chaos on the surface
will take before it comes down here to
the oceans and the response of aquaman
is well if that time comes and i will
deal with it then but that's if that
time comes at the moment i don't really
care it's not my concern here and so
it's a pretty significant moment because
one of the things that we learn is that
wonder woman had basically been banished
from themselves she's not allowed back
anymore that she's lost her title of
princess that the reality here is that
with themaskira you know when she had
left that place and gone out into the
world she was supposed to be an
ambassador and she was supposed to make
the world a better place but she never
did she's not welcome back anymore and
so she has she's no longer the the
person that we knew but one of the other
things that goes on is you have this uh
this moment where superman actually
finally tracks down or really it's more
like speedy he finally tracks down uh
magog and then he actually travels to
meet him now in a lot of ways it's one
of these things that's fearful because
what this does is it tells us how things
got this bad why the justice league
disbanded why superman basically quit
the whole nine yards that what magog is
doing is he's actually out in kansas
seemingly trying to rebuild to a degree
and that's when superman asks like what
are you doing out here and you kind of
have this moment where magog basically
kind of pokes fun at him right just sort
of rustles his feathers a little bit
gives him a bit of a hard time
superman's not necessarily having it but
the mad dogs was like don't you remember
like you're the one who caused all this
right like you're the reason why things
are the way they are and that's when we
end up getting this bit of a flashback
and what we find out is that at some
previous point in time the joker had
shown up to the daily planet in
metropolis and massacred everybody 92
men and lois lane one woman and the
result of that is that with her being
killed along with jimmy olsen and
everybody else that the joker was
captured and the joker was put on trial
but before the trial could could
actually take place magog showed up and
killed the joker and instead of humanity
condemning this action and saying that's
a problem humanity cheered the action on
they were like yes the joker had to go
the joker had to die and what this did
is it led to superman becoming
disheartened by the fact that everybody
was okay with it the magog was
eventually arrested and then when he was
put on trial he was acquitted and so it
was essentially humanity saying we're
okay with the fact that a metahuman took
the law into their own hands and killed
a villain we don't really believe in
truth and justice anymore we believe in
doing whatever it takes to win now the
reality is that really is what it takes
that really is the case there are some
people out there that just have to die
the results of this is what you had
really the bigger issue that you had
here is that the magog wasn't really any
measure of a leader himself he was just
a guy out there with power and so when
he killed the joker and became the kind
of face of this new generation of
superheroes and superman abandoned his
role and the justice league disbanded as
well it left the stage open for all
these meta humans to rise now that's the
big difference there i do champion the
idea that there are some people out
there where the world would just be
better off without them that as a
society you have to create a kind of
structure right you can't have this kind
of open-ended idea where it's like
everybody can do whatever they want to
that makes them happy you know like you
do have to have a rigid and firm
structure on how society functions
otherwise you start running into all
kinds of problems and yes like maggot
killing the joker isn't him crossing a
line sure but if this was like superman
who had done it or something like that
things could potentially turn out
different now i know a lot of people are
going to say like but rob injustice so
on and so forth superman was right in
injustice he was 100 right humanity
couldn't be trusted to make the world a
better place so superman had to do it
for them that if superman didn't step in
and do that humanity would have
eventually wiped out the whole world and
is what of what use is freedom to a
society that will use that freedom to
destroy itself i would say freedom is
useless at that point and so the thing
about this is that you have this kind of
situation where ultimately the magog
comes clean i don't know why i keep
saying the mad god but the but mega i
think it's because i'm used to saying
the man gog from uh from the thor comics
at marvel
but magog comes clean and what's been
happening is he has this enormous weight
that he carries around because he never
wanted this he never wanted to be the
face of some new generation of vigilante
that showed up and turned the world into
a hellhole he never wanted to be that he
never wanted the entirety to the entire
destruction of kansas that's never what
he wanted here and so what he's what he
tells superman is i'm sorry right like
this is all your fault you were supposed
to be better than us you were supposed
to be great you were supposed to be the
one that showed us a better way you
weren't supposed to quit you were
supposed to show me what i was doing
wrong you were supposed to guide us at a
time when the world really actually
needed you you quit you gave up and so
he says like i'm tired of dealing with
all these ghosts that haunt me all these
like a million ghosts all these people
in kansas that haunt me punish me lock
me away kill me just make the ghost go
away right make my guilty conscience
disappear and that's when superman tells
wonder woman we are at war and the
reason why this matters is because
wonder woman having been a warrior and
so on and so forth the big concern of
the spectre and norman mckay is that if
anybody was going to push superman over
that edge and send him into a place
where he would potentially become a
dictator it would be wonder woman
because when you're a hammer everything
is a nail and so when you're wonder
woman and all you live to do is fight
and like defeat the enemy the idea of
things like nuance right the idea of not
everybody is an inherent bad guy and not
everybody needs to be treated the same
way that kind of thing goes away now to
a degree that's true treating people
decently does not mean treating people
equitably that if you are a person who
has known nothing but war in conflict if
someone showed up to you with a kind and
caring and gentle hand you would likely
see them as being weak because the
defining attribute of what makes a
person strong is whether they can
withstand and cope with that war type
environment right physical and emotional
and mental strength that's what defines
a valuable person you would see that
kind person as being weak whereas if you
are someone who comes from a kind and
gentle place you would look at somebody
who uses overbearing force to get their
point across as somebody who's
inherently weak because you value
strength through kindness and compassion
so again one of the things that wonder
woman doesn't really seem to have a good
grasp of is the nuance of that
everything can be treated the same way
so that's going to be an element that's
actually going to be very very important
as all of this goes on but one of the
things that superman does here is he
actually travels to apocalypse which is
the realm of dark side to visit with
orion now this is kind of a small little
deviation here right kind of a small
little thing it's not a great big huge
moment and in fact word had reached the
ears of superman that basically darkseid
had been overthrown by his son orion and
that when that had happened orion had
seized control of apocalypse but when
superman came here asking how can i as a
person right this this individual who's
supposed to somehow show these meta
humans a better way what do i do about
the ones who don't want a better way and
the response of orion is that's the
issue that i ran into when i took over
apocalypse and i replaced darkseid my
thought was that all these people who
live on apocalypse would love the idea
of freedom they would love the idea of
being able to live their lives as they
see they saw fit but what i found is
that because that's the li the only life
they ever knew they don't want a
different life than that because it's
scary it's fearful the idea of change
giving them freedom is something they've
never known before comfort comes in
being a prisoner right and so because of
that when i gave them that freedom they
rejected it they rebuked it they didn't
want to have any of that right by just
literally getting rid of darkseid and no
leader operating here they put me in his
place because they wanted someone to
rule them they wanted someone to conquer
them right to control them to tell them
where to go and what to do because for
us as people and you can kind of argue
by extension the people on apocalypse we
want to be controlled why we want
direction we want to be told where do
you go what do you know where to go what
to do how to act we want to say we don't
we like to say no i don't want that i
want to have a life where i can make my
own choices and do my own thing and live
my life as i see fit but when push comes
to shove and it really comes down to it
a lot of people out there who have the
opportunity to forge their own path
choose not to because it's scary it's
outside of what they're used to and if
being being given the choice between
stepping into that box or staying in the
box they're in they'll choose the box
they're in and that's that's the the
wisdom that orion offers here if what
they understand is being conquered if
what humanity and these people
understand is being made to do things by
force if what they understand is
imprisonment and pain then give them
that give them what it is that makes
them comfortable and so while it's not
necessarily superman approaching this
from the perspective of we're going to
make people suffer what he does is out
there in kansas this irradiated
wasteland he starts building a prison he
literally starts building together this
giant prison system where all those
individuals who stand against him will
be housed and so as the final little bit
of this video what we end up doing is
switching over to the mankind liberation
front where you have lex luthor
effectively telling everybody they've
brought someone on board that will
essentially help them to change the tide
to achieve their goal and effectively
eliminate the entire meta-human issue
once and for all allowing humanity to
effectively step into the role of being
the sole inheritors of the world and
this person is revealed to be batman
accompanied by ted cord and dinah lance
and oliver queen with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end thank you all for watching and i
will catch you all later
peace